foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
christian nationalism
the christian taliban the american
taliban the gqp
the american fascist maga trumpism
whatever the hell you want to call it
whatever great words you can come up
with to describe
the threat to our democracy use those
words eh it doesn't matter to me
i think christian taliban sounds good i
think american taliban sounds good i
think christian nationalism
sounds great that's the phrase they're
using christian nationalism they're like
yeah yeah we like that we're gonna have
a handmade stale that's what we want and
we're gonna take it even further
i'm not [ __ ] you
this is this is real i i've been telling
you this over and over and over again
they're not going to stop they're not
going to stop at roe they're not going
to stop it taking away women's bodily
autonomy they don't want them to vote
they don't want black people to have
rights they don't want lgbtq people to
have rights they're fascist
and they're saying it out loud there's
no quiet part it's not quiet anymore
it's not quiet
actually you think the taliban is bad
you think the taliban is bad don't go
vote in the 2020 midterms 2022 midterms
don't go vote see what happens you
you'll be like oh taliban [ __ ]
and long for the taliban if you don't go
vote in the 2022 midterms
you even have dumb [ __ ] like joe rogan
buying into this crystal fascist [ __ ]
this
american taliban
christian nationalism [ __ ] where
he's like yeah ron desantis he'd be a
good president
i mean except for the whole
joe rogan loves weeding and loves to do
drugs except for that
you are a dumb [ __ ] rogan you
are a stupid son of a [ __ ] if you if
you aren't aware when joe rogan endorsed
bernie sanders that he had no idea what
the [ __ ] he was endorsing or what he was
doing you are not you you do not have
enough brain cells
to operate
oh you norris bernie he must be good he
endorsed burning because he doesn't know
[ __ ] from
shinola
just like he's endorsing ronda's hand
you dumb [ __ ] this this stupid
bastard his entire audience is like oh
the government can't tell us what to do
freedom of speech the [ __ ] the
government's gonna tell you what you can
and cannot say and here's ron desantis
down in [ __ ] florida telling disney
what they can and cannot
say in their [ __ ] movies and they're
cartoons
the let's go brandon nazis show up
at [ __ ] disney world
with nazi flags to protest
that disney doesn't have their freedom
of speech their fascist
and if we let christian nationalism take
hold in this country which it's starting
to folks i don't know if you i don't
know if you notice the supreme court or
not they seem to be bought and paid for
surprise surprise surprise
no [ __ ] [ __ ]
of course they're bought and paid for
we've known this for months years
and elections have consequences dummies
yep they got consequences the
consequence
the consequence of the 2020 election of
you getting out and saying no to fascism
and saying no to american fascism manga
trumpism
fascism in a manga hat
you doing your duty your civic duty for
your democracy and making sure to vote
against that
had consequences
now
we today are paying for the consequences
of the choices we made all the way back
in 2016.
the choice not to engage or to engage
improperly in our democracy we are
paying for that decision today we are
seeing the supreme court absolutely kill
and gut the clean air act
the federal government doesn't have the
right to make sure its citizens have
clean air to breathe look we are the
[ __ ] federal government you [ __ ]
dummies it's us
it's our epa
it's our air
i don't give a [ __ ] what some dumb [ __ ]
on the supreme court says i don't give a
[ __ ] what some fascist says i don't give
a [ __ ] what someone wants to talk about
with the epa it's our heir it's our
country it's our government it's our
legislator it's our court
we really need to pluck our heads out of
our [ __ ] asses here
block them out of our own asses and
realize this is us
it's us we are the [ __ ] people we
still have the vote today
they're gonna move on the vote folks
they're already gonna hear a case out of
north carolina they're gonna move on the
vote [ __ ]
you better this may be the last time you
get to free and fair vote
this time right here in 2022 it may be
one of the last times you get the free
and fair vote you better make that
[ __ ] count
and i'm not just talking about your vote
i'm talking about everyone you know even
if they're not registered get them
registered and educate them on what the
[ __ ] is going on
do you want the christian nationalist
the american taliban the christian
taliban to control the economy
do you want them to control your [ __ ]
public schools what are you [ __ ] out
of your mind
that's who they are even liz cheney says
it liz cheney last night at the ronald
reagan institute the [ __ ] library for
their first god
their first conservative god ronald
reagan
liz cheney stands at the podium and says
you cannot be both a loyalist to donald
trump and a loyalist to the constitution
you cannot do it
liz cheney darth vader jr
she's no she's no [ __ ] friend of
rights
she's no friend of liberalism
she's not even a friend of liberal
democracy she just wants her party back
and boy is she doing a bang-up job of
trying to get it back
and i applaud her for it yeah sure fine
get your old you know thin veiled
fascism i would much rather deal with
thin bale fascism in this country
then outright american taliban christian
taliban christian nationalism handmaid's
tale type [ __ ]
that's where we're headed that's what
they want
doubt me i don't i don't give a [ __ ]
you can doubt me all you want
it's not hard to see it's not hard to
notice what the [ __ ] they want
and ron desantis is a perfect picture of
it down in florida he's the blueprint
rogan says oh i i like that rhonda
sanchez he'll take away all the [ __ ] i
say i love like freedom of speech drugs
my freedom i like him
[ __ ] joe rogan
you are a dumb [ __ ] you are a
stupid stupid son of a [ __ ]
stop talking about [ __ ] you don't know
about you dumb [ __ ]
bernie tyron desantis what does that
tell you
what does that tell you about joe rogan
what does that tell you about ron
desantis
what does that tell you about bernie
sanders
it says a lot it says a lot in our
political discourse
we are not [ __ ] paying attention and
you have to
you have to pay attention you have to
get your neighbors your friends
your community members your colleagues
your fellow parishioners
to understand what is at stake
it's it's not just
the supreme court it's not just the
legislator it's not just the presidency
it's the [ __ ] document that holds the
entire democracy together
that's what's at stake
they're saying that the supreme court
said this morning that we the people the
federal government doesn't have the
right
to dictate
that we the people the [ __ ] federal
government itself
doesn't have the right to tell
corporations that we need clean air
what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
they don't believe this nonsense it's
but that's that decision is bought and
paid for by the way
that decision is bought and paid for
as you see the decision made in biden
versus texas with the remaining mexico
policy
that that the trump lodites
put in place of our federal government
which was a dumb [ __ ] policy in the
first place it's ridiculous it does the
exact opposite of what they say it's
supposed to do it it causes a problem
which is pure
trumpism in its
style is to cause chaos and then act
like you cleaned up the chaos you
created
it's really [ __ ] dumb
but biden and the biden administration
said [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're not doing the
remain in mexico
[ __ ] it was challenged
and they won
the reason why they won that decision
and it was kavanaugh roberts that voted
with the three liberal justices in that
decision the reason why is because
there's there's no money in that
you know [ __ ] i mean there's a lot of
money in those people coming across the
border and actually giving us migrant
labor which we need in our economy
that's one reason why our economy hasn't
has been suffering with the whole labor
thing is because we are used to in this
country for decades and decades having
migrant labor but we don't have it
because of dumb [ __ ]
four years of dumb [ __ ]
politicized those people
ravaged those people
them their children
treated them as inhumane as they
possibly could didn't even treat
they are not humans in his eyes
and we have the effects in our economy
with labor because of it
because they don't want anybody with
brown skin coming to our country
babies don't give us anything
nothing they're not worth anything or
that you know like [ __ ] labor
we've relied on migrant labor you
[ __ ] idiots
it's not rocket science or rocket
surgery
the supreme court is out of [ __ ]
control
but it's well within our control if we
do something
it's our government it's our three
branches there's checks and balances
folks built in and the one check on the
supreme court is the legislator
oh but tony they don't have the votes
yeah they don't have the votes because
we aren't voting for the people that
need the votes to change this [ __ ]
you have to go vote for the people who
will change this [ __ ] oh but tony
democrats and republicans are the same
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
you are a stupid [ __ ]
and go sit out in the election if you
think that democrats and republicans are
the same and watch what happens
you think you think these these american
christian taliban are gonna give a [ __ ]
about clean air you think they're gonna
give a [ __ ]
about your medical marijuana you think
they're gonna give a [ __ ] about your
student debt [ __ ] you or your health
care get the [ __ ] out of here they don't
give two shits they want to take the
voting rights away from women
this supreme court needs to be changed
and we
we need to change it that's right we
need to change it
it's up to us
and it's again it's not just you marking
your ballot
it's not just you marking your bow you
have to stay [ __ ] pissed you have to
have strategic [ __ ] outrage
towards your family your friends your
parishioners your colleagues people
your children's friends at school their
parents you have to engage now is the
time
they're telling you what they want
they're telling you what they want to do
and as and as the trump
the manga king crashes to the ground
which is exactly what's going to happen
here you're going to watch these other
fascists emerge
that's why that's why joe rogan's
talking about ron desantis because he's
just on the next train he's trying to
appease his [ __ ] stupid audience
that's all he's trying to do today it's
trump tomorrow it's desantis
he doesn't give a [ __ ] because he
doesn't think
that they'll come after him
as long as i capitulate they won't come
after me
stupid bastard
uh we're getting uh some news here uh it
looks like
let's see is
is kbj
katangi brown jackson being sworn in i
don't know if there's a uh there's a
clip of it yet
uh speaking of supreme court news
katangi brown jackson
um it's gonna be sworn in today we we
had the breaking news yesterday that
justice stephen breyer
formally retired with a letter as of
today which means that
tangie brown jackson yes it looks like a
danger brown jackson is going to be
sworn in as justice
uh she has been sworn in it is uh
breaking uh let me let me go to some me
let's get that there
[Music]
here is the uh here's the ap story
breaking katangi brown jackson has been
sworn in the supreme court shattering
the glass ceiling as the first black
woman on the nation's highest court 51
year old jackson is the court's
116th justice
oh
it just
it is amazing to me that on a day like
today where we have little victories
little victories people in this country
don't understand that elections have
consequences this is exactly the
consequence that we want folks right
here
this is your consequence
you went out and you voted against
fascism and here's the consequence of
that the consequence is that we get the
very first black woman on our nation's
highest supreme court she's 51 years old
she'll be there for 30 years at least
and a good justice she will be for the
people
because she looks like the united states
of america
look at his face she looks like the
united states
this is a patriot
someone who will take her duty seriously
who doesn't cry
tears in her beer
who takes every word every decision
seriously
we have an unserious court they're
bought and paid for i mean why would you
think they're serious
when
they're in the pocket when that someone
is in their pocket
with kavanagh and gorsuch
thomas alito and roberts
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
six three decisions but it's up to us
it's up to us to give the legislator the
power that they have
in checks and balances it's up to us
just like we gave we gave the united
states senate
the ability
to confirm katangi brown jackson we did
that we did it
that's the consequence yes it
consequence doesn't necessarily have to
be a bad thing for us for we the people
it was in 2016
it was in 2014 when we left
2012 when we left mitch mcconnell be the
majority leader
you cannot you cannot
negate the fact that the reason why we
have this decision today is because
mitch mcconnell
was made majority leader of the senate
we did that we the voters
it is a reflection of what we did or did
not do
and we are living today with those
consequences and we will continue with
these consequences if we do not pluck
our heads out of our asses
and engage now
now is the time to engage rather you
peacefully protest
at these uh at these row versus wade
protest
for women's rights
rather you make sure you're making phone
calls writing letters sending texts
donating money to campaigns that are
pro-democracy
and that is the key pro-democracy is the
key here
that is the key
to get back to some sort of [ __ ]
normalcy in our democracy
not this [ __ ] christian
american taliban
that has control over parts of our
government you know it's kind of funny
the right wingers the tea party you
remember the tea party
when barack obama became the first black
president of the united states oh my god
we're not we're taxed enough already
[ __ ] nonsense
they barreled us
into this christian american taliban
that's when it really
all started to fester
i'll give you an example
they were terrified they kept saying i
heard i heard my white relatives say
this stupid [ __ ]
barack obama or he wants sharia law
he wants sharia law
oh my god the first black president
named barack obama with a funny name he
gonna give us sharia law that's what
they would say over and over and over
and over and over again sharia law
sharia law sharia law
and here we are today in our country
living with the consequences of letting
the people who were terrified of sharia
law which is all nonsense
now taking over our parts of our
governments
whether it be states local or federal
and pressing american christian sharia
law
the american christian taliban with
american national with the with
christian american nationalism it is
absolutely [ __ ] bonkers
that we did not see this coming
i did not see this coming they are a
bunch of [ __ ] right-wing nazis let's
go brandon nazis
and we have to stop them we
we have to stop them you can't just say
oh well
the senate should do something now now
right now or else or else what you're
not gonna vote
or else what
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you you people need to get off your ass
stop making excuses and take your
[ __ ] democracy back that's what you
need to do
that's what needs to happen
stop making excuses
stop
that oh what we got we got 50 votes god
damn it that should be enough well it's
not enough it's not enough no matter
what you say no matter how many times
you say it no matter who you blame it on
it's not enough
it's not enough jesus christ kirsten
cinema says this morning that she was
not she will not break the filibuster
for the exception of roe v wade to
codify it
president biden says yes we should break
the filibuster with the exception to
codify roe v wade
pearson cinema says nope not gonna do it
i'm paid too much money to make sure
that we don't break the filibuster
guess what we can't do anything about
kirsten cinema not a goddamn thing can't
do it there's nothing to do what are you
gonna do she's not being re-elected
stop stop [ __ ] bitching about her
stop bitching about joe manchin he's not
gonna change his [ __ ] mind
there are races where you can [ __ ] do
something
there are races right now happening
jesus christ warnock's gonna [ __ ]
have a heyday with walker in georgia
make sure that is a guarantee that's
what you should do
make sure tim ryan wins in ohio not
[ __ ] jd vance that goddamn christian
fascist
you want you want more christian
american taliban just vote for jd vance
in ohio
here really put the chastity belt on you
and take away your vote women
so work against it go [ __ ] get them
make sure the arizona senator race is
locked
we have more bad news in missouri where
john woods enters the race as an
independent
what the [ __ ] an independent go run as a
republican you piece of [ __ ]
danforth is off the mark here in
missouri he's gonna get eric greitens
elected
stop cracking up the vote that can elect
moderate and independent and
not
not
american taliban republicans to vote for
someone who's pro-democracy
who's not a fascist stop doing that [ __ ]
stop it
this third-party nonsense get the [ __ ]
out of here john woods is not going to
win in missouri as an independent he's
only going to rip away votes from
whoever the democrat
nominee will be and give eric greitens
that [ __ ] rhino hunter that goddamn
nazi
the ability to be united state senator
stop
stop it
it's okay for us to understand how
government works it is okay for us to do
that it is okay to come to grips with
that we do not have a legislator in the
senate
right now that can break the filibuster
to do the things that we need to do to
save our democracy we don't have it
right now but we have a chance there is
a chance this year during a midterm to
do that you just have to make your
decision and help others make their
decision too
and to engage
it's the most important part of
democracy and they're about to rip it
away from you
if you do not use your vote
and i'm not just talking about marking
your ballot i'm talking about the rights
you have to register people i'm talking
about the rights you have to campaign
i'm talking about the rights you have to
make phone calls to write letters
to make sure that pro-democracy
candidates are standing in the way of
these american christian fascists
this christian nationalism [ __ ]
that's bought and paid for
it's time you can do that you have that
right still at this point
but if you don't use it you may lose it
so use it
pick up the hammer of democracy and
smash them with it
that's why they hate it they [ __ ]
hate democracy because it is their enemy
just look at this woman here
they hate her because she is democracy
that's what it looks like folks
that's what democracy looks like
and you did that
you put one of the smartest people on
the court
even in this dark day of the supreme
court in this dark day the supreme court
that is that is trying hard
to push the accelerator to take us back
in this country
beyond the time that we even remember
but we today in this dark day the
supreme court there is light there is a
shining light
and her name is katangi brown jackson
and she is now the first black supreme
court justice on the court
your
work in the democracy has consequences
folks and this is a hell of a good
consequence
a hell of a good consequence
and you should not stop here don't stop
here they won't stop at taking the
rights don't stop at working hard to get
the smartest the brightest that looks
like america
in our government whether it be the
legislative branch whether it be the
executive branch or here in this example
with justice katangi brown jackson
in the judicial
branch of our government we the people
control this
never forget that
and if you do
you will lose your rights
it is time now
to fight hard for consequences just like
we fought hard
in 2020 to make sure that we had the
consequence
of this beautiful smart
the most qualified person to ever be
sworn in as a supreme court justice and
i am proud to say that she is our
our supreme court justice not bought and
paid for
thank you justice katangi brown jackson
thank you
and i look forward to all the decisions
that you make for our country
everyone stick around we will be right
back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
sticking around through the break
[Music]
supreme court is going to kill
leonard
tell us we the people that we can't have
clean there what in the actual [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we have the ability we have the rights
still to change this now it's going to
take a little bit of it i'm telling you
it's democracy's hard
it ain't easy that's that's that's why
these fascists hate democracy that's why
they hate it it gives people equality it
gives people equity it gives people
rights and it's difficult it's [ __ ]
hard it's [ __ ] hard
you know a bunch of white trumped up
people don't want [ __ ] they don't want
[ __ ] to be hard they want to be really
easy that's what authoritarians do is
make [ __ ] really easy they just wave a
magic wand
and they say that's what i want and
that's what we're gonna do bing
[ __ ] the people [ __ ] the voices [ __ ] who
wants what
and where
they don't give a [ __ ]
not in my country not in my democracy i
don't know about you
there's a lot of video that we gotta get
to today a shitload a video that we got
to get to today and uh gabe sanchez
should be joining us here in a minute
to
go through some of the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
i'm telling you
it's a lot of [ __ ] i want to show
you some [ __ ] videos
of these christian nationalists
and how dangerous it is not just not
just
to
the women's right to their bodily
autonomy but even their vote they're
coming after it and i told you months
ago that they they're gonna do it and
they're gonna say it
and they're not gonna stop they're not
gonna stop i'm telling you listen to me
when i tell you this they are going to
continue to try to take away your rights
if you if you if you don't listen if you
don't take them seriously they will do
it
doubt me
so let's get to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends start the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
johnny michael's podcast we've reached
the part of the podcast where we surf
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
on the [ __ ] list roundup
you know we do this show every single
weekday we've got a ton of new listeners
here holy moly thank you thank you very
much
all
the new listeners out there we broadcast
every single weekday monday through
friday live on youtube twitter twitch
and simulcast to the midas touch
facebook page
every
single
weekday
so don't forget to hit subscribe to the
youtube channel you don't want to miss a
single episode and even if you do it's
okay
they're right there they're always i
mean unless they ban them but we haven't
had one band in a while
i haven't had one taken down in a while
it's been a long time
so
make sure make sure you subscribe to the
youtube channel also go over and follow
us on twitter because tomorrow's friday
tomorrow's friday everyone knows here
that friday is bonehead of the week
so go follow us at the tony michaels pod
the bonehead of the week poll will be in
our twitter page it'll also be on our
youtube page
because we post it on youtube
as gabe knows we post it on twitter and
there you are
yeah we post we post it everywhere
everyone
do you think we have enough um elector
votes to do three states facebook
youtube and but i know i don't see the
problem you'd have to do it from midas
touch yeah i would have to really i'd
have to bug the suits every thursday i'd
have to really bug the suits up yeah and
it's disgusting you know we got this
machine this locomotive is moving right
see here's the here's the thing here's
the thing
is we simulcast to the minus touch
facebook page every single weekday and
i've got the key to that door right yeah
to broadcast i do not have the the the
key and and maybe i could call jordy
because i know i know every once in a
while brett
he he kind of he kind of gives jordy um
you know like the password or something
right right and and and you know
everything every so often
he'll trust him right with the password
any and he totally he he totally does
something he's not supposed to do and
that take the password back what so
maybe just maybe we can try on thursday
to see if we can uh get jordy
to float the pole in there you know then
maybe brett would take the password away
from us i don't know i don't know yeah
it's one of those things we got to be
careful we got to be careful with this
are there that many people on facebook
that uh
well i guess there's like a
not a half a little less than a half
people watching right now or the yeah
people on youtube so yeah
i'm telling you i'm telling you the
facebook audience is getting bigger and
bigger yeah and we appreciate having you
out there on the minus facebook page
make sure to follow us on twitter again
at the tonymichaelspod and if you don't
if you don't have a twitter account we
completely understand that's why we went
ahead and put it on youtube so that you
could subscribe over there you can vote
over there so we have two
places that you can vote so and really
honestly you know this isn't like our
free and fair elections in this country
a person could you know stack the vote
yeah i know
you know like a trump supporter would
right here
just like there was no widespread voter
fraud in the election because it would
require a lot of votes to swing it you
know well in any given week you might
have you might fluctuate from you know
several hundred to over a thousand votes
or something like that but you would
need to coordinate a very big effort
to say oh they swing the bonehead
right right yeah so well you know
again if anyone isn't aware out there
every single thursday we do a bonehead
of the week poll we we select three
boneheads
and i'm i'm sure a supreme court justice
is going to make their way on this
week's list and just from the
the decisions that have come down today
oh yeah yeah it's kind of kind of gross
but here's the thing is uh
we're we're gonna we're gonna do a poll
every single thursday with three
boneheads uh sometimes me and gabe
collaborate sometimes he's like nope
these are the three boneheads i'm
putting them up and then and then i put
them over on youtube but you guys get to
vote you get to decide who is the
bonehead of the week we do not rig it
it's up to you guys and then we actually
on friday in the second hour of the show
because we do two hours every single
weekday but on fridays in the second
hour we break down your vote
of bonehead of the week whoever you
select and then we throw in a couple of
new people in there for a dishonorable
mention in the alpha cuck because we
discovered as we started to do this bone
of the week
that man you can never rely on the three
people
on thursday like friday morning like
right before sometimes there's always
well even
well it was uh even even from day one
when we had it it was the dishonorable
mention because we were going through
and i was like nah no no he's like this
i forgot who it was i have to go back
and look but i was like this person
needs to be like their own dedicated
this is an [ __ ]
and then it wasn't until later which we
mentioned yesterday about ethan schmidt
and when we saw that and then we were
talking oh yeah alpha cuck and it was
like oh maybe we have a new thing here
speaking of that because we talked about
carrie lake yesterday um and that's one
of the videos i want to show i've got a
lot of video i want to show today that
we gotta go carrie lake the fake oh my
god this this is a this is a uh primary
um uh debate here
talking about election right i don't
know if i'll play the whole thing
because it's it's hard to watch this
[ __ ] this lunatic talk about this
stuff
but watch the moderator try to control
her dumb ass when she's saying all kinds
of just just [ __ ] lies watch this
carrie we'll start with you great
illegitimate
president what does that mean
he what is it what the hell does that
mean it's so funny he's like what the
[ __ ] does that mean like what what do
you mean he's an illegitimate president
he is actually the legitimate president
not only was he elected he was certified
and he's sworn in which actually makes
him legitimate regardless of how he got
elected i mean george w bush didn't win
the popular vote donald trump didn't win
the popular vote and they were sworn in
they were technically the legitimate
president they were sworn in they were
in the office
so what what does that mean is what he
says lost the election and he shouldn't
be in the white house we had a corrupt
election i'd actually like to ask
everybody on the stage if they would
agree we had a corrupt stolen election
raise your hand
did we i i love this part because she
immediately and everyone else is like
yeah yeah sure sure sure i'll go along
with that i would like to i'm not going
now i'm not sure who the opponent is
here in the in the blue blazer um
she apparently does not believe that the
election was stolen she's got at least
half a brain right right well that means
she'll get at least you know maybe ten
percent of the republican vote then
right i mean it really is she's like
look look i i see the writing on the
wall or the ketchup on the wall and i
gotta tell you right now that it might
not be the most wise decision to keep
pushing this thing considering that
there are lawsuits from dominion against
multiple entities like newsmax oan fox
news robert murdoch rudy giuliani you
know and the likes that's why fox news
wouldn't wouldn't advertise her [ __ ]
[ __ ] when she was on the show the
other day yeah we watched that clip
yesterday bears like you're a dumbass
yeah all those things you're saying are
[ __ ] lies like you said it out he's
like look i'm not he's like i'm not
getting thrown into this lawsuit all i'm
gonna say is uh he did win you're wrong
and let's go back to these uh these drag
photos
well right and and then she she
spreads lies about how she wasn't for
drag queens before she was against them
right it just it's ridiculous because
she's it's the tail that wags the dog
and really if you watch it when we watch
this clip here i want to tell the
audience this this really smells like
she's being paid to say this stuff let's
watch just you're stunned well let me
let me let me connections right now
okay
i want to know why you think that the
the election was either rigged stolen or
whatever the phrase might be
it was interrupted corrupt and stolen
whatever i looked at the evidence we did
a forensics
and this is the nonsense right this
moderator should say you're [ __ ]
lying you're lying not only are you
lying to the american people but you are
lying to the people watching this debate
here you're lying and the reason why
you're lying is because if you have the
evidence if it's so compelling then go
[ __ ] turn it over right show us and
then she then she talks about the and
i'll tell you we actually we need to
stream this [ __ ] movie and rip it
apart this 2000 mules because listen
yeah listen to the [ __ ] where she
she cites that she is endorsed by dinesh
d'souza as if that's a great thing like
what the [ __ ]
so we
i know you don't believe that our
election was stolen karen i believe
there's a reason absolutely there's a
reason that there are people who want to
tell you why there's a reason that the
people who want to see election
integrity are endorsing i just got the
endorsement of dinesh d'souza oh boy all
the america first people
all the amer all the fascists all the
time all the nazis all the nazis
nick fuentes and all of them all the
[ __ ] nazis endorsed me she's like
look look look i got a group of people
they're whiter than white let me tell
you they are the best of people
they told me that they believe what i
have to say because i'm a fascist
they're a facet fascist we're all just a
group of fascists here
right i mean who in their right mind
would ever use the term i was endorsed
by dinesh d'souza like that's the first
group that's the first person you want
to say like hey
you can believe me because i've been
validated or vetted or i've been
approved or i've been you know endorsed
by and then you say dinesh d'souza like
when you've got uh bill barr under oath
in a deposition
say that not only was the election fraud
claims
[ __ ]
quote
[ __ ] he then goes on to say that the
2000 mules thing is a [ __ ] laughing
stock like it's a joke
and that that that trump wanted to use
it as evidence is hilarious but you've
got someone there and and the first
thing they say is well i've been
endorsed by dinesh
you're off to a bad [ __ ] start like
that's not the person that's the same
person that tried to defend trump when
he said thailand and then said well
actually regional people of the area
might say thailand and everyone's like
no shut the [ __ ] up that's not how you
say
right well you know the other the other
crazy part about the dinesh d'souza
thing is she should be like dinesh
deceased oh i don't know him i never met
him in my life this whole this whole
[ __ ] that trump did with with cassidy
hutchinson that should be her go-to yeah
like that should actually be the
political goat like to say that like i
was endorsed by a felon like not great
right it doesn't bode well but here
speaking speaking of future felons here
uh
and and people who who say i don't know
that person
this is donald trump's uh he's on some
trader tv news network i'm not sure
exactly wake up america yeah you know
what's funny is they call they call all
of us wokers and they're they're they're
[ __ ] they literally
literally are projecting at every single
turn here because they have no other
option right here is here is donald
trump on woker america
um
a trader tv news network talking about
cassidy hutchinson
listen to what he calls her because gabe
i actually do not know what this [ __ ]
means okay i do not i haven't i haven't
watched this so let's see
a woman
is living in fantasyland she's a social
climber if you call it she's a social
client what the [ __ ] does that even mean
i'm not sure what this i don't know if
he's referring to social media or like
like society in itself yeah i think what
what he's referring to is she's climbing
the rungs of the ladder like you would
do like in like you're all like oh that
person's just like uh you know they're
um like they're climbing the corporate
ladder i mean you mean like you mean
like a piece of white trash in new york
who who uses their dad's money to to
pretend to buy a bunch of buildings
pretend to buy a bunch of casinos and
try to act like you're an elite act like
you're a billionaire is that the kind of
social climber that you're talking about
yeah that's that's almost verbatim the
type of social okay
it sounds like he knows it's just you
know it's a it's a gold foil rap turd is
what it is what trump is and that's the
social climber that he is you know this
is so [ __ ] ridiculous and this isn't
that long and i got a couple clips of
this nonsense now again everyone's like
hey stop giving the propaga i got this
this morning stop giving the propaganda
oxygen like look the only way to stop
this nonsense is to call it out as
nonsense people you can't ignore the
[ __ ] they're not ignoring him
they are not ignoring him on newsmax if
you ignore this or people like this and
don't call it out for the people who are
like no don't give them attention if you
don't call it out then come november
you're gonna be like how the [ __ ] did
this person get elected because we
didn't call it out we didn't say what it
was we didn't if you didn't realize
exactly if you didn't realize that this
dumb [ __ ] crazy fascist idiot was
running in whatever district county
state whatever it might be and then
november you say whoa
where did they come from i would have
totally run against that person if that
was the bar that we were setting
that is what's happening here so if you
don't know that these people these
fascists these crazy lunatics are
actually running
then how do we know how to prevent them
from taking office if they go the other
thing is we have to know what they're
saying we have to know what they're
saying so we can rebut it in the
narrative exactly folks propaganda isn't
a bad word
it's used badly okay propaganda is used
badly in our political discourse by
[ __ ] chuckleheads like this
we have to use truth and propaganda to
get out the truth so people [ __ ] know
i'm sick and tired of democrats and
liberals oh we can't politicize this it
looks bad who gives a [ __ ] rat's ass
if you don't they will because they are
that's right
well right here listen to what he says
here's a good example of it social uh i
i think it's just a shame that this is
happening to our country and we don't
have any republicans up there to just be
we don't have any republicans up there
[ __ ] it's only been republicans
yeah only been republicans who have
refudiated you and by the way cassidy
hutchison was [ __ ]
deposed and questioned in [ __ ] public
in front of cameras by a republican yep
by a [ __ ] republican one i can't
[ __ ] stand frankly right i know i
mean when you when you start agreeing
with a couple of those republicans on
the committee you're like oh [ __ ] i
don't know maybe they have a point here
like this is this is [ __ ]
this timeline we are in bizarro world
right now where we are we are a green
and you know the friend or the enemy of
my enemy is my friend like that is what
is happening right here but this whole
thing yeah it's it's
trump saying this stuff is ridiculous we
should not ignore it we have to stay
focused we need to pay attention we
cannot lose
you know through the weeds get lost in
the weeds here of what's going on they
have a goal they have an agenda we've
seen it in the supreme court we see what
they're doing we cannot let up
well here is here's liz cheney last
night because she gave some words now
this is important folks this is very
important where she is at saying these
words
she is at the the ronald reagan
institute at the ronald reagan
presidential library in simi valley
california okay
this is the republican who is not a
liberal by any stretch of the
imagination she is so unliberal that she
turned on her sisters uh her lgbt rights
to get her seat as the wyoming
uh representative at large in
wyoming now
she is the one who who questioned
cassidy hutchinson almost the entire
hearing that is absolutely designed to
destroy this image that trump won and
that he thinks he won it's
completely destroyed it the other day so
much so he's such a sore loser that he
was throwing his plate against the wall
and they had to clean up the ketchup off
the [ __ ] white house wall but listen
to liz cheney's words here and most
importantly at the very end
listen to all the republicans clapping
for what the the dismount that she has
at this part of the speech listen
picture is coming into view with the
january 6th committee
it has become clear
that the efforts donald trump oversaw
and engaged in were even more chilling
and more threatening than we could have
imagined now remember who she's talking
to here she's not talking to i mean
she's talking to the country yeah yeah
she's talking to a room of people who
came to the ronald reagan institute at
the ronald reagan presidential library
to listen to her give this speech it was
billed
as what is the state of the republican
party right that is how it was built she
is she is placing herself right now
through this committee through the
speech and the action she takes as the
person that is against trump as the
future leader of this party i've been
saying that for months i've been saying
that all the way back to january 6 of
this year the one-year anniversary of
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup when the
only elected republican standing on the
floor in solidarity with nancy pelosi
and democrats was liz cheney and the
only unelected or not serving an office
republican was her father darth vader
dick cheney yeah now i said at the time
that was sending a huge [ __ ] signal
not just to trump but to the entire
republican party and here she is
here she is several months later after
she's laid out evidence that donald
trump is not for democracy is not going
to keep the republican party in power
here she is laying out why she stood
there with her father and what the
consequences are of that imagery
as we have shown
donald trump attempted to overturn the
presidential election
he attempted to stay in office and to
prevent the peaceful transfer of
presidential
power he summoned a mob to washington
he knew they were armed on january 6. he
knew they were angry
and he directed the violent mob to march
on the capitol
in order to delay or prevent
completely the counting of electoral
votes
he attempted to go there with them
and when the violence was underway he
refused to take action to tell the
rioters to leave
which is uh you know
love hate liz cheney which i'm again i'm
not a fan she does a great job of
summing up exactly what the testimony
was the other day uh in this speech and
she delivers it directly to the ears of
republicans look folks
republicans out there
that aren't exactly trumpers that don't
exactly agree with this
but they're elected and they have to
kind of go along to get along they're
looking for anything anything to grasp
onto here and maybe just maybe liz
cheney gives them the ability to grasp
onto something to get us back to some
sort of reality because that's the
problem that we have
is this this nonsense this reality tv
republican
this christian nationalism as if this
was what founders wanted and all these
[ __ ] lies about what our country is
what our country isn't what it's been
over the decades and centuries it's all
nonsense and if we can just get back to
these republicans having that thin
veiled [ __ ] fascism that's called
conservatism we may be better off we may
be able to do this democracy thing
better if they actually participated in
instead of trying to overturn it but
listen to what she says here at the end
about her republicans her her for her
actual republicans in her party and
donald trump and the constitution this
is important
instead he incited further violence
by tweeting that the vice president
mike pence was a coward
he said quote mike deserves it
and he didn't want to do anything in
response to the hang mike pence chance
undeniable
it's
also painful for republicans to accept
here it is and i think we all have to
recognize and understand what it means
to say those words and what it means
that those things happened
but it the the reality that we face
today as republicans
as we think about the choice in front of
us
we have to choose because republicans
cannot both be loyal to donald trump and
loyal to the constitution
at this moment
so they're in that moment when she says
and she's trying to advance the speech
forward but in that moment when she says
republicans cannot be both loyal to
donald trump
and the constitution she's laying it out
in bare terms you are not a republican
if you
are not for the constitution and if you
are for the constitution you are not in
support of trump she lays it out and as
she goes water let's back it up just a
bit
watch what happens when she tries to
advance after that line the entire room
erupts in applause eyes and understand
what it means to say those words and
what it means that those things happened
but it the the reality that we face
today as republicans
as we think about the choice in front of
us
we have to choose because republicans
cannot both be loyal to donald trump
and loyal to the constitution
at this moment
yep and there's the applause
if that's not room for people to move to
the pro-democracy side of this country
regardless of where you end up on the
ideological spectrum here no matter
where you end up whether you're
republican democrat independent moderate
whatever the hell you want to call
yourself
if you do not understand that at this
point you are against the constitution
of the united states of america if you
are in support of trump no matter how
low level you are if you're just going
to his rallies and you have no idea
about politics you're just a cult member
or if you're the goddamn arizona speaker
of the house
rusty bowers
if you're supporting donald trump you
are not in support of our government our
constitution and our country you are
unpatriotic
is what she is saying here and i i again
i'm not a fan of liz cheney i actually
you know i call her darth vader jr
because i believe and soon enough she
will be our mortal enemy yeah yeah
i mean
she will be the one trying to tear down
our rights trying to take away rights
from people uh with her thin bail
fascism called conservatism i remember
that even though she's you know even
though she's doing us this solid for the
january 6 committee as the supreme court
is coming out with these decisions he's
very much in support of these things
right absolutely absolutely
and and
we have to be we but we have to know the
difference we have to know the
difference between um what her style of
fascism is and what their style of
fascism is we have to understand that i
do not believe i do not believe that liz
cheney is a christian nationalist now
she definitely definitely is a fascist
but she's not a christian nationalist i
don't believe that for a minute um i
mean
her ideas are dangerous just like this
guy's ideas are dangerous this guy is
this this guy seems to be a danger to
himself did you see this video
yeah i i started to watch it and it
reminds me of and i might you know i'm
not going to ruin the joke i don't want
someone to take it
okay okay yeah yeah you might are you
going to make a video or do a tweet or
something is that what you're going to
uh yeah yeah i either will remake the
video or i might dub the video i'm not
sure but this style video reminds me of
a type of commercial so this john voigt
video is different from the ones that
we've seen recently yeah because he's
actually backlight backdrop hey yeah man
they're putting some production value in
there yeah yeah no no longer is he
standing in front of that wrinkled uh us
flag right it's he looks like he's in a
basement somewhere um with it with his
cell phone or something right they
actually put a camera up they got a
backdrop it's it's bad they got some
lighting on him
you know what i you know i think they
they were like hey these crazy bat [ __ ]
videos are spreading around like crazy
so let's give them some production value
yeah let's stop making them look like
[ __ ]
although he could have combed his
[ __ ] hair a little better here i'm
just saying
i'm just saying jon voight though he
does seem like he's broken out of a
nursing home or something to give this
video it really and it looks like they
feed him these lines
because he's talking what he's talking
about here in this video is impeaching
joe biden which he's basically i
i tweeted that he's endorsing kamala for
president like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like yeah when people are
like oh we gotta impeach fighting okay
next up and like we gotta impeach harris
okay next up like everyone you're going
through is going to end up being some
democrat or someone that you believe is
against the republican party right yeah
well it's here's an instance when
everyone in the country is like impeach
that [ __ ] with trump we
understood that mike pence was going to
be our president we understood that but
we knew that the danger of mike pence
was just ever so slightly
not as much as the danger of donald
trump the only problem with meg pence is
the fact that he doesn't he doesn't
cause a lot of drama he is the like the
perfect politician for them because what
he'll do is he won't cause any
controversy he won't say anything
outlandish he'll you know like subtly
say some things and pass some bills and
sign some things in that and he'll get
it along and people probably wouldn't
even know but it's the reason for trump
that we were
i guess so aware of what was happening
because you're like holy [ __ ] he said
the quiet part out loud now they're just
talking out loud about it
and i think in many ways like yeah
that's a you know there's a pro and a
con to it and i think the biggest con to
mike pence if he were to actually take
over
was that he was going to be
more or less like a puppet for them he
was going to stay and do what they
wanted which was going to be dangerous
that was dangerous but it was less
dangerous even right right right yeah he
was going to he wasn't going to shoot
nukes at someone right because his
finger wasn't anywhere close to button
but with trump you know he was throwing
ketchup against the wall and had his
finger ready to go right right well
let's listen to this this weirdo
talk about i don't know he says all
these stuff you know this
and i just listened to this idiot
they've we're all angry
and let's
remember why
it starts with the seat of the president
of the united states
he has wronged this nation's glory
he's what does that mean wrong this
nation's got like what does he give an
example do these people have examples of
how joe blyden
like i you know i i mean
you know
there's things that i could criticize
about joe biden
but wrong this country's glory what does
that even [ __ ] mean
i don't know just like oh yeah like that
thing i'm gonna show you i'm gonna show
you a couple videos from the good liars
which is fantastic
um and and we'll see what they're
messaging uh more about this message but
what does that even mean i don't know
it's taken down our morals what our true
gift of the land of the free
see the more that
[ __ ] wait another second having him
dictate our path
what
we can't wait another second now here's
the thing here's the thing that jon
voight is missing here
the thing that he's missing his
elections have consequences jon boyd and
the body that actually impeaches joe
biden
is the house of representatives so i
think what he's trying to do here is say
go vote
so that they can impeach him i believe
that's what he's saying
but he's not saying that he's saying we
can't wait another second like now we
have to impeach him now which is not a
thing just like we can't break the
filibuster to codify rue right
that's not a thing right now that's just
not a reality it doesn't it's not it's
not a thing that can happen now we can
pressure them but it's not going to
happen but here he's living in delusion
let's listen let us work together
get him out
and make this country what she stands
for greatness
come on kamala harris is greatness
that's what it stands for yeah okay
like literally he's saying get out biden
and let's get someone like do they
really think if they impeach
biden that trump becomes president is
that what they think yes they do it's
this these are the same people that
thought that trump was biden and biden
was trump and there was some face-off
situation happening and so when trump
was really taken to prison it was going
to be biden and actually trump was in
the biden body skin and he was the
president oh yeah yeah this is the whole
the military is going to come in yeah
this is the whole thing and they're like
oh it's going to happen in march it's
going to happen in you know in in july
it's going to happen they kept moving
the date you know like
almost as frequently as mike lindell
changes the date of when he's going to
have this nine-zero supreme court
decision to show that there was election
fraud who is another person that's being
sued by uh dominion so you know all
these people are [ __ ] idiots and they
they you know they see a facebook meme
they see a post online and they go
that's truth i won't need to back it up
or find any sort of uh evidence or or or
citations or sources for it
and they just say oh you know what
you know
i mean you don't need that many sources
to know that if you get rid of a
president the next person in line right
i mean there's one source that they can
yeah there's one source that they keep
uh pushing as their their uh their bible
which is the constitution and i'm pretty
sure in the constitution it lays out a
lot of these amendments and how certain
things go into place there's like the
25th amendment that was considered for
trump like it was actually a
consideration at the time there's all
these things and it's like they don't
need a bunch of historical legal texts
or documents it's just one there's the
one that they that they believe so much
in the one that they actually want to go
against what it says right now for
people like lauren bobert but none of
that makes sense they're they they
they have no
justification or no background on it
they're just like we need to impeach him
on what grounds he's taking away the
greatness of this country the glory of
god
what is that here's the thing here's the
thing john boyd is a great actor i don't
know if you guys have watched him in
movies he really is a great actor
unfortunately
i kind of like when he's in acting in
movies because he's he's good at it i
mean i'll be objective but he's this is
but i think that's what he's doing here
don't you think that's what he's doing
oh i think this is john voight writing
his own national treasure of three
script like that's what he's looking for
oh i think i think he didn't write this
i think he got paid to say this [ __ ] in
front oh yeah yeah but what i'm saying
is like these
these snippets that we've seen online
you know talking about the constitution
talking about the president talking
about greatness and glory like he has
really just taken his
his national treasure three
character that character the character
and then said this is pretty fun you
know what
let's do more of this let's keep saying
these things that make no sense
whatsoever but they feel good in a movie
and we'll just make it a small little
clip right exactly [ __ ] crazy let's
let's listen to this batshit craziness
and how he wants kamala harris to be
president the land of opportunity the
land
of the greatest soil our forefathers
fought for
don't let this president biden tear down
every inch that was sacrificed with
blood sweat and tears for his dictation
of lies what i urge all
to see truths i urge all to make a
difference
is this going to end up this is a
commercial for truth social that's what
it is he's going to be like and now in
order to get all the truths out we need
to go to truth social
rights yeah sponsored by president trump
it's like where the real legitimate
president president trump is now telling
us truths about cassidy hutchinson
right well
you talk you talk about [ __ ]
knuckleheads on the internet trying to
spouse truth i forget what's this guy's
name this guy's name is um
uh let's see vince vincent james
yeah he he is a [ __ ] nazi like
straight up not hiding it he says yes
absolutely we are the christian taliban
says it out loud i think this is why
christian taliban is uh trending this
morning now adam kinzinger have referred
to part of his party as the christian
taliban but listen the reason why adam
kindlinger is referring to them is
because of knuckleheads like this
you think that jon voight [ __ ] that word
salad that he said is dangerous but
they're stoking the same people with
that john voigt video as this video
listen i told you months ago that they
would come after the woman's vote doubt
me [ __ ] doubt me listen to this
[ __ ] there are hundreds of thousands of
people that are listening to this guy
spew this hate and this [ __ ] nonsense
listen we are the christian taliban this
is
this is the era
of christian nationalism
christian nationalism is on the rise and
people are thirsty for it they are
did you hear that folks
christian nationalism is on the rise and
people are thirsty for it they are
stoking hate and people are buying hate
they know it
they [ __ ] and know it and they're gonna
exploit it at every single measure
that's what he means they're thirsty
they're thirsty they'll pay anything for
someone to say this stuff and to
perpetuate this stuff and not only say
it and perpetuate it but put it into law
because that is where you get your
really your your [ __ ] your bones off
that is really how you [ __ ] this country
listen to what this guy says about the
women's vote and handmaid's tale it do
not look away
hungry for this
and we are the christian taliban and we
will not stop until the handmaid's tale
is a reality and even worse than that
to be honest
yes we do have to start rolling back
there was this article from the atlantic
was like well alito is on a mission to
roll back the rights of of women that
roll back the past hundred years of
rights that were given to women yes
yes that is that is what we're doing and
uh it's only going to get worse for you
from did you hear that folks
i maybe maybe i should play this
[ __ ] again so you will take me
seriously of what these boneheads want
here we are the christian taliban this
is
this is the era of christian nationalism
christian nationalism is on the rise and
people are thirsty for it they are
hungry for this
and we are the christian taliban and we
will not stop until the handmaid's tale
is a reality and even worse than that
to be honest
yes we do have to start rolling back the
there was this article from the atlantic
was like well alito is on a mission to
roll back the rights of of women that
roll back the past hundred years of
rights that were given to women yes
yes that is that is what we're doing and
uh it's only going to get worse for you
from here
and that's exactly what i've been saying
is that they're going to come for your
rights they're going to come for your
vote i don't give a [ __ ] they're not
going to stop they're not going to quit
they're not going to stop
so you have to stop them you have to you
have to work hard this election the next
election because they're coming for your
rights and the reason why this guy
doesn't want women to vote is because he
knows that they'll vote against
his his fascist views
women aren't going to vote in this
country for his fascist views they're
not going to do you know one thing i do
want to bring up is you know he says oh
it's going to be like handmaid's tale
did he does he know how handmaid's tale
ends
like did did did he
watch the seasons and be like oh [ __ ]
season four that was okay right we're
ran in this thing
um
because he's one of those people that
would be like oh yeah i'm the master
well i'm sorry but the master [ __ ]
dies bro spoiler alert right but these
people
have the audacity the goal the
the the ability as you know these incels
want to come out and say
oh well it's going to be like handmaid's
tale or worse right you know and before
we said it we're like we said it on the
show multiple times it is not just about
abortions it wasn't just roe v wade this
is just one way to pry open the door or
the can of worms and say okay now we've
gone after these rights and we can use
that as precedent and following so forth
and so forth and so forth whether it's
same-sex contraception interracial any
other state rights we can now use it as
precedent so
these people that come after me like oh
we wanted you know like uh handmaid's
tale or worse oh yeah that's what
alito's doing like
here's he's smiling and he's being a
smart actor right right and i know that
he's obviously like i'm going to say
this [ __ ] and i'm going to get it
clipped out and that's what people are
going to get outraged about but he
really he really does believe it
even if he doesn't believe it even he
doesn't believe it he's perpetuating
this stuff into the fascist movement and
they are buying it hook line sinker and
they are believing this stuff just like
they believe that jfk jr was somehow
going to appear in dallas right just
like they believed like you said earlier
that that somehow joe biden and donald
trump switch faces and [ __ ] he knows
that's what these people will believe
and he knows he knows that politicians
out there like ron desantis that [ __ ]
let's go brandon nazi down in florida
will set the blueprint for what he wants
to have happen
he doesn't give a [ __ ] who goes and
takes away women's rights he just wants
it done yeah he just wants it done
that's what they want right it's what
they want and we have to fight back
history has shown us that you know i'll
say it again that fascism is boring
they are not inventive they are not
creative they use the same identical
[ __ ] play
that they've done before they just take
it out and say yeah we'll do the same
thing again and each time
we have defeated fascism and brought it
down right it's like it's like these
these patriots these patriots have
i have uh sorry my phone just went off
uh have completely
ignored history right these people that
say oh we're patriots and we we we
totally uh love this country and then
you find out that these actually are
just in-cell patriots that are trying to
you know
thrust themselves into
uh the
the majority of the country that doesn't
want what the minority that is them you
know actually believes in and whether he
actually believes the [ __ ] or not which
i i believe that he does you know he is
is fanning the flames he's throwing
kerosene onto the fire yeah
the vincent james guy exactly you know
what scares me about vincent james
vincent james looks a lot more polished
he's uh than like nick fuentes nick
fuentes is obviously a joke right well
he's got the whole you know he's got the
youtube plaque and the streamer
background and he's got oh i've got a
bookshelf in the back which i probably
have not read any of those [ __ ] books
that is a very very polished version of
the america first nick fuentes nazi type
of [ __ ] right well speaking of nazis um
here is the good liars with eric
greitens well you remember this video
about eric greitens where he's
he's going on he's going full-on fascist
inside this video
um a political ad that he put out to say
he's going to kill dissidents inside his
party now with guns and the army and the
military and the swat team um the good
liars here catch up to eric greitens
look it looks like they're at a county
fair or something here our county avenue
i mean they're always they're in some
back lot hoe dunk
[ __ ] corn field where you know
everyone else is like no we don't want
to uh let you rent the space
right because they're like well that's
good
right right but watch once the good
liars is
and she asked
about
is he asking about the ad it's hilarious
your ad is the talk of the the country
right now i'm eric greitens navy seal
and today we're going rhino hunting
you're comparing these rhinos almost to
as if you're running into them in nature
or something right it's big game hunting
obviously no of course right it
obviously shows at the left
which has no sense of humor
oh it's so funny gabe he he it's
obviously a metaphor it's satire it's
parody this is not satire parody
eric greitens doesn't know the
definition of satire parody right
because satire parody he would actually
ha and
the good liars go to it he would either
went to a quote-unquote rhino like the
animal yeah yeah you know he would have
been hunting the animal right or on the
mailbox there would have been spelled
like the animal right exactly with like
emblem right and and and i'll say it
again like
the way in which is like oh it's
actually you know it's either it's gonna
be rhino or it's a metaphor it's like
it's a metaphor well here's the thing if
it's a metaphor
then you either willingly misspelled
rhino on the [ __ ] thing right or
you were intentionally trying to show
the point that you would kill people who
would go against you and the maggot
country right right
absolutely well listen listen listen to
how
of course the good liars
the the two
good liars are some of the best
political satirists um that that we have
in our country right now and they're
willing to get in the trenches to do
political satire and is fantastic and
they're doing a great service for the
country by using their skills of
political satire and political parody
here but
listen to when
eric greitens tries to tell one of the
best political satirists in the country
what political satire is this is [ __ ]
beautiful right outlaw metaphors
[Applause]
get a rhino hunting permit there's no
bagging limit no tagging limit and it
doesn't expire it's like as if it's a
rhinoceros right but then you go to
human house
well you know i think i think what was
what was really clear about that was
that it was it was a metaphor what was
what was clear about is i was i was
clearly trying to use
trying to use the fact that rhino and
rhino rhyme and that rhino is an animal
and i was not doing a metaphor i was not
doing satire parody i was just trying to
make people think that i'm going to kill
other people in my party right and
and that and i used those words so that
i could air this political ad wherever i
wanted because i used the words in a
certain way well he's not actually a
metaphor they're like uh he's like oh
well it's a metaphor and it's like yeah
yeah so like it's a rhino but then you
go to human human's house and like the
next bit part of that bit would be like
oh yeah and then we encountered like
some rhinos having [ __ ] dinner or
something in the house like it was like
the three the three bears or even on the
mailbox it was like the rhinos and then
right right right right
like it was a family of rhinos something
that would actually make it a metaphor
not the literal thing that you're trying
to say is i want to kill republicans in
name only yeah yeah because you're
you're not
you never allude that there are animals
in the [ __ ] in the ad there's no
imagery anywhere that it's animals none
whatsoever
none you're you're you're es you're
making the assumption that people will
think haha funny funny it's not funny
here greitens you're threatening to
murder people right that are dissidents
it could be totally different if you
then went you know you're out in like
the wilderness and you were like you
know buckshot shooting a like uh a
wooden cutout of a rhino right like it
would be that really like hunting rhino
it's like oh god rhino rhino not like oh
republicans you're breaking into a
republican's home telling them that if
they don't agree to what you have to say
or what trump has to say or all the
delusional white supremacist nazis have
to say that you're going to [ __ ] hunt
them down and shoot them like that's it
is idiotic for him to attempt to be like
it's it's a metaphor let me tell you
what satire is okay
well the other thing too about eric
greitens is no one is aware which i
think a lot of people are aware
especially uh
watchers of our show because i've gone
after him several times is this is the
former disgraced governor who was
shuffled out of office because
he duct taped his hairdresser naked to a
treadmill blindfolded her took pictures
of her and then used those pictures in
that moment as blackmail for her to give
him a [ __ ] yeah her hand for her to
for him to rape her totally fine right
totally not crazy type stuff and you
want to i mean you want to talk about
the company you keep don junior right
right mr uh
booger burgers sugar junior uh is
hanging out with this guy and they're
shooting stuff and make threatening
remarks in a previous video it says like
oh if liberals want to come after we're
ready to go we're going to go hunt some
liberals like
that's the type of person it's always
with the guns with these little dick
energy [ __ ]
don't you know don't you notice that
like they have they have no man they're
not not a [ __ ] shred of manliness in
them yeah if they always have to use
guns to threaten their enemies like what
are you talking about right what the f
you guys are such [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
would i would imagine that you couldn't
please a woman because you have such
little dick energy you [ __ ] little
[ __ ] they always have to use pew pew
pew pew i'm i'm such a big tough guy i
would imagine that eric greitens
probably drives a truck that has big
huge tires and it's got have you ever
seen these uh these these metals
yeah the metal or plastic yeah yeah that
hang from the back of the tailgate he
probably also had those cartoon
characters that's always pissing on
something yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so he's probably like pissing on the
republican logo or something like that
yeah oh yeah yeah i mean the same people
who need to use ar-15s to hunt uh
hogs or hunt uh prairie dogs you know
[ __ ] super small animals are the same
men who probably couldn't even pleasure
a woman right these are the same women
these are the same men who wouldn't be
able to find the g-spot these are the
things and that's that's the reason why
they say this stuff that's the reason
why they get all upset is because they
that's why they don't want women to have
boats and they want handmaid's tail that
way they don't have to listen to how
they have little dick energy and and
women can denigrate them for their
unmanliness i mean this is this i mean i
would even go as far as to say these
people who have you know they're like oh
my i'm gonna conceal my gun in my pocket
you know and then goes up to a woman to
sexually assault her and she goes oh my
god what is that
are you are you excited like what do you
know is that something or in your keys
or something you're excited to see me
and they're like oh no no that's just my
gun
amanda life says premature ejaculators
oh 100
100 percent
one pump and blow ozzy says big guns
small penis i mean this is all
projectional
energy but listen listen to how
to how they uh he gets so he gets so
frightened by by the actual
satire and political parody that is
before him
he gets frightened and runs away it's
like as if it's a rhinoceros right but
then you go to human house
well you know i think i think what was
what was really clear about that was
that it was it was a metaphor but it was
it was in like a human house so that's
why i was kind of like because it was
like big game hunting but then it was
like you went to like a human house i
think everybody everybody who has a
sense of humor recognized kind of the
parody well i thought why did he keep
pretty funny but then i was like but
then he's going to human house with the
swat team yeah i gotta get going because
that then
i love i love that eric greitens is
trying to say that that that the video
he made to threaten dissidents in his
party is a metaphor satire and parody
yeah and one of the best political
satirists is standing there using
political satire to tear apart that
argument it's [ __ ] hilarious exactly
and he gets so scared of it he's like
whoa
whoa look at the look at the time i
gotta go kill me some rhinos like oh my
god dude what in the actual i mean you
know
i've said it before and i'll say it
again
there are no conservative comedians
tell me tell me one that is actually
well
they're no funny right right okay sorry
show me one funny conservative comedian
just like i would say show me one
conservative website or app that was
built by conservatives and run by
conservatives that is actually well done
like i have not seen
that in my career as a designer and a
developer like not seen it and it is i
believe mainly due to the fact that they
have no ability
to uh to to really like go in and have
creative thoughts have original thoughts
right again they're fascists they just
keep reusing the same thing like truth
social like oh i like twitter
like that's what it is right there's
nothing new there happy face they're
like oh what are these retreats we gotta
they change they change a couple of
colors they change a couple of colors
that's all it is there's nothing new on
that app it is a complete copy and paste
new colors
some new words which [ __ ] reach roots
he's out there truthing what is this
like they couldn't even get they
couldn't even get creative about how to
name the app
well speaking of the truth in trump uh
the republican accountability project
put together this video
and it and it splices together
the testimony that was given by cassidy
hutchinson
and they say here in the tweet we went
back and watched trump's speech on
january six
sure seems to back up what cassie
hutcheson said under oath yesterday
because everyone's questioning her
because of the secret service thing and
the [ __ ] the ketchup story right
they're like oh she lied under oath the
problem is they're saying she lied about
ketchup and the secret service the two
things are not the crime that's not the
crime that's not actually the crime but
here is a great video that shows you the
test her testifying and then
we can see it as clear as day exactly
what his intentions were and she backs
it up in her testimony here it is when
we were in the tent behind the stage
he was very concerned about the shot
meaning the photograph that we would get
because the rally space wasn't full
i want to back it up here because this
is great this is a good shot this is the
this is the same guy who had sean spicer
say it was the biggest uh attendance
crowd on record right and it's like make
sure to know that it's like did you look
at obama's in 2008 holy [ __ ] man that
was pretty big dude that was pretty big
you know and i i don't know it looks
like um maybe i don't know is there
probably 2 000 maybe um 1500 people here
in this picture something like that i
mean there's a lot of people in this
picture but not the number that he says
of course right i mean it's a big
[ __ ] lie but but watch what the the
footage that they pulled of donald trump
talking on the stage
this is him talking on this stage the
day of january 6 and talking about this
crowd listen
i turned on today i looked
and i saw thousands of people here but
you don't see hundreds of thousands of
people behind you
now of course so he's so he's referring
to the people behind them the people who
are not inside
of the ellipse because they had a
barrier right you know we know from the
testimony the other day in the hearing
we know they actually had a perimeter
that these people had to get through
they had to go through security of
secret service to be inside this
perimeter
of the ellipse and there was a word that
kept being used mags did you know what
that word meant in the moment gabe i was
kind of confused i was like no not much
but once they i was like oh metal
detectors okay right right metal
detectors and it's a specific type of
metal detector that detects weapons
apparently yeah like which is like a
totally normal reasonable thing that you
would have when you have someone who's
like of a certain state uh status you
know like the president you mean guns
are dangerous
it's almost like that would be putting
guns in a crowded place with a lot of
people who are very emotional can't
handle their emotions
is very dangerous huh well we'll get to
that here in a minute but let's listen
to more of this video that accountable
um the republican accountability put
together i knew he wanted it full and he
was angry at that we weren't letting
people through the mags with weapons
with the secret service deemed weapons
so there there that word mag is um that
nancy hutchinson that the secret service
were deeming
weapons right because that's the other
thing is the testimony showed that not
only did they have firearms because they
proved it with uh they um evidence from
the police scanners that the police were
following they were keeping track of
people who actually had firearms on the
ground that weren't inside that
perimeter but were at an ndc that day
that were there for the support of trump
they were even climbing trees to watch
the speech because they couldn't get
inside the ellipse inside that perimeter
and that's what he was saying is let
those people in
i don't care they're not going to shoot
me and you'll see it here just weapons
and i'd love to have if those
tens of thousands of people would be
allowed
the military the secret service and we
want to thank you and the police law
enforcement great you're doing a great
job
but i'd love it if they could be allowed
to come up here with us is that possible
can you just let them come up please
i was in the i was in the vicinity of a
conversation where i overheard the
president say something's the effect of
you know i don't even care that they
have weapons they're not here to hurt me
let them in let my people in they can
march the capitol after the rally's over
they can march from they can march from
the ellipse take the effing mags away
all those hundreds of thousands of
people back there
move them up please
so there you are he's saying it but
listen to this line right after that
listen yeah
so that that that's it
when you go back
to her saying let them let them in so
she's testifying to it here under oath
and we talked about her notebook the
other day that has all the notes in it
uh cassidy hutchinson is very organized
very intelligent person here um she's
got all of her notes she's got it lined
out of exactly what happened but again
listen to this this is very important
she says he's he she testified to say he
let them in let my people in they can
march the capital after the rally is
over they can march from they can march
from the ellipse take the effing mags
away
all those hundreds of thousands of
people back there
move them up please yeah
move them up please yeah
so in other words put the mags down he's
not going to say it out loud in front of
the microphone because he knows
he knows what that would be that would
be uh evidence but he always does this
he always edges right up
right up to the [ __ ] truth of what he
really wants
always always projecting now so i really
appreciate republican accountability
project putting that clip together um
and showing that yeah she's not [ __ ]
lying
she was compelled by a subpoena to come
in and tell the truth
now you know again cassidy hutchinson
may
uh in in the future in in the history of
this event of the january sixth select
committee be
be shown as a hero here but um
and in fact she is doing the right thing
by telling the truth about she's doing
her job that's right she's doing her
civic duty she's doing her patriotic
duty here um again i i wish she would
have done it many many many months ago
many many months ago but let's watch a
clip here i told you we would get to
the den dangerous guns thing and this
this part about here's his refudiation
on the woker america on newsmax um this
trader tv news network here's his
reaction in an interview he looks really
[ __ ] disheveled here by the way i
mean his hair is all disheveled he looks
old and decrepit but but let's but let's
go well you know
fast food will do that to you so what he
says about this let's see
you know some whack job can say this
stuff and get away with it and other
things that i wanted guns at my rally
okay now i'm speaking why would i want
guns i don't want people having standing
with guns
in my rally i don't remember she said
ar-15s at the capitol she wasn't
complete that's hilarious come on tell
me tell me this tell me this is not
[ __ ]
like what
so you believe that if there's no guns
that you're safe listen to this you know
some whack job can someone stop and get
away with it and other things that i
want another thing is my rally
okay now i'm speaking why would i want
guns i don't want people having standing
with guns jesus christ can you imagine
how dangerous it would be if people
brought guns to my rally
oh boy imagine can you even imagine that
would be crazy what the [ __ ] come on get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
this is ridiculous now do schools
[ __ ] now do schools do
elementary schools talk about the safety
of elementary schools you piece of [ __ ]
um we have um some news i think
um
we have liz cheney here has
announced
i haven't seen video of it but there is
just the article that i sent you about
her
um
speaking on the topic
of the january 6 committee and the
witness tampering that she alluded to at
the end of uh of tuesday's hearing okay
so so it looks like um they're going to
uh refer
uh criminal referrals here is reuters uh
let me pull this up here
uh reuters is reporting january 6
committee may make criminal referrals on
witness tampering uh liz cheney says
we noticed at the end of the
uh hearing the other day that there was
witness tampering
and they showed text messages or emails
it's very hard to see what they didn't
really say what the proof was they just
have it in quotes and gabe what they
were doing i thought is they were
warning those people who said those
things and they know they've said those
things like we got you [ __ ] like yeah
we already we already you know we
already have a record of it now whether
those people have um
you know i'm not saying their [ __ ] has
been tapped but you know it is one of
those things where
if they're i mean maybe they haven't and
they're just giving them a fair warning
but or maybe it's like look we already
have the records and the documentation
from text messages or recorded phone
calls that you've had with these people
that have been witnesses
it certainly it certainly feels like
that i believe that i i and i said it
from day one i was like who else who
else thinks that this is rudy giuliani
not all not both of them but i
definitely think that the message one
where it says
this person you know believes that you
are doing a great job and that you are
loyal and like these are all the type of
language things that trump would tell
someone else and that someone would not
have their own creative ability to to
paraphrase they're just going to say
exactly what was written down to say
make sure they say this
right well um
actually after the hearing the other day
i actually asked michael cohen
um i asked
i asked michael cohen to react to
um this fact about the witness tampering
here's a little bit of what he said here
um here it is
i know i guess you call it truthing i
i'm not really sure um i want to bring
those up real quick i think this is it
is this it
says he hardly who wanted to be part of
the defense team no this isn't this
isn't the clip i'm looking for i'm sorry
let me find the other clip on youtube
because uh but it was it was about the
witness tampering in particular and
that's the important part here of the
witness tampering i'll see if i can can
you see if you can find that uh youtube
link for me gabe it should be on my
touch youtube channel and there's a
couple michael uh cohen reactions there
uh from the from the hearing but the one
in particular that i'm looking for is
the one about the witness tampering and
maybe it may be the one the first one
that they posted after the hearing but
uh because i want to get michael's
reaction there uh you've got another
link here for me that you've you've
posted and what what is this here
this is one that uh caitlyn just sent me
that was about texas and they're
removing the word slavery
from the books baby that's what they're
going for
uh it says only in texas you know the
texas education agency is proposing the
state board of education who decides
state curriculum to change the word
slavery to
involuntary relocation
what
involuntary relocation okay here's the
tweet
um only in texas the texas education
agency is proposing the state board of
education who decide state curriculum
they're changing the word from slavery
to involuntary relocation you know
what's funny about this
is these fox are the ones that are
complaining about critical race theory
yeah and they're actually acting in the
way
that is the opposite of what they're
claiming people are doing
like they're doing the thing that people
are doing just the opposite way right
like
you need to tell the truth you need to
tell history right like we shouldn't be
scared of history we shouldn't be scared
to talk about slavery in this country in
a way look it's gonna be uncomfortable
we did some very [ __ ] up things as a
country i mean like a lot of countries
did a lot of [ __ ] up things but
america especially
and to to rewrite to uh take a
revisionist
approach to say uh slavery
hot button topic don't want to discuss
it very controversial you know what we
need to say something that's a little
bit softer something that's like a
little bit easier to digest so my kid
little timmy doesn't get so guilty that
he's the white kid in the class to say
oh well it's all these white people that
ruined the country because they came in
and they raped and they pillaged and
they enslaved all these people or they
brought people over who were slaves from
africa
like that's you know these parents who
have their own projected guilt or
insecurity and they put it on their
children and they say we need to change
these books guys because i can't have my
kid talking about it and i can't have my
kid asking these questions because it's
going to make me feel bad and it's like
i'm sorry but that's history you can't
just rewrite it
and that's what texas is trying to do
here they're trying to
reformulate
the phrasing or the word
so that slavery isn't even a topic
you're like oh what was it oh well it
was involuntary relocation it was
they went against
it went against what they wanted but we
moved them over
then and the second link i showed you is
uh an actual um
oh it clipped from from a book not using
the involuntary relocation but using
moving out they they decided they had to
move out
so so not only changing a language but
actually um
they're rewriting it there it's
revisionist storytelling revisionist
history that's what republicans like to
do oh you lost president trump no i
didn't it was rigged
you lost by eight million votes a bunch
of illegals did it i tell you like
that's the same type of stuff if it
doesn't go with their their narrative it
doesn't go with the message that they're
trying to show that hey we're when we're
we won we're big we're strong we're
america
they get insecure and they need to
retell it a different way
to poke holes in the actual truth
that you're saying hey these are the
facts here's the evidence here's the
actual numbers and they're savory
slavery wasn't that bad it was just a
relocation for crying out loud and this
is just another example oh my god
and here's this is the uh is this the
image from the workbook that i have here
moving out when their european sellers
arrived they needed
land to live on oh yeah those white
people need land to live on the first
nations people agreed to move to
different areas to make room for new
south that's exactly what happened
they agreed to move yeah sure yeah sure
if you're gonna if you're gonna murder
us and commit genocide against this
we'll we'll completely move to different
land voluntarily get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] like oh oh sorry you
guys came you you need it you need a
spot it's like when you know when you're
if you have a dog your dog jumps on the
bed and you're like all right you can
only have this small area and then your
dog like somehow kicks you off the bed
that's kind of what's happening here
they're like oh well you know we just
wanted to make room so we figured why
not give these people that we've never
seen in our lives the people that are
violent against us why don't we just say
hey you guys can have it we'll giddy up
and go and it's like
no that's not what happened you know or
it's like oh we're going to take these
people on boats and put them in chains
and make them work uh out hours and days
in in in in terrible connect conditions
to say that i own you now and then
they're going to say no well involuntary
relocation like no we're not going to
sugarcoat it we're not going to rewrite
it we're going to call what it is it was
slavery it was against their will it was
terrible it was disgusting it was vile
you can't just take that away and that's
what republicans want to do because
what's going to do is it's going to make
them look bad the people that do want to
take away uh you know uh segregation or
want to take away women's rights you
know they're they're trying to re
revision
this whole scenario to say well it's
actually not as bad as you guys make it
seem right okay we're not actually
fascist we're just trying to make sure
that it's states rights and try to go
under that umbrella versus we're trying
to take all your rights away that's what
we're doing we want we want the state's
rights to oppress you that's what we
want at mcconnell and there's some
breaking news with mitch mcconnell uh he
calls biden's comments on scotus
dangerous not the scotus itself but the
comments about oh my god
joe biden tell him that here's more of
the truth that's dangerous to them yeah
he he goes on to say attacking a core
american institute institution like the
supreme court from the world stage
is below the dignity of the president oh
you know that would be that would be
great if american president wouldn't
attack core american institutions that
would be great if they didn't have like
a violent mob that would go attack
american institutions you know below the
dignity of the president get the [ __ ]
out of here with this [ __ ] this is such
nonsense
and of course shame on mitch mcconnell
because that's all he has
yeah well this you know mitch mcconnell
again is the guy who was like we're
gonna force through this nominee you you
can't you know when uh
when uh
scalia passed away was like oh no no no
we we can't do it guys we're you know
it was more than a year i think a lesson
here maybe 11 months 10 months or
whatever and it was like well we're too
close we are too close to the election
we cannot possibly do this and they made
you know they you know mitch mcconnell
said he's like my my my job here my role
here my number one
objective is to make sure that
that obama is a sitting duck present
that he can't do [ __ ] all right and so
they're going to throw up a nomination
and we're going to say no we're not
going to actually even touch this thing
and then you've got a month two months
or less than that people have already
voted weeks people have already [ __ ]
voted
for the president that they want to have
and mitch mcconnell goes guys guys look
look uh i know what i said before about
the whole like uh you know it was too
close thing but we're now weeks a month
away from the election and we need to
make sure that we get our last nominee
in before trump ultimately gets uh fired
from his job well we we know today the
another big supreme court justice news
is katangi brown jackson is sworn in as
the united states supreme court justice
she's now justice contangie brown
jackson and she is the first black woman
uh to ever serve on the court now which
really gets in um oh man they do not
like that well see here's the thing
about john cornyn not happy about that
right well here's the thing about
katangi brown jackson is angie brown
jackson's not only the
the first black woman which is uh
historic and actually a good thing for
our country for our court to look like
the people of this country
here's the thing
is we watched a bunch of porn obsessed
morons porn obsessed fascists like ted
cruz and josh hawley try to accuse her
of being some kind of weird porno person
and it didn't work it didn't work no one
fell for it the country didn't fall for
it and here she is this is one of the
best pictures
that i think uh come out of
the actual nomination
and the confirmation of justice katangi
brown jackson is her daughter
looking at her
knowing that her mother is going to be a
united states supreme court justice
but more more than anything that young
women can now look up just like her
daughter is looking up to her mother
to justice katangi brown jackson and yes
even though today is a dark day
uh for the supreme court where they're
trying to make it to where us the people
and and over the last several weeks but
today in the particular and over the
last week overturning roe uh making it
to where states don't have the right to
regulate weapons uh that are destroying
and killing children and killing other
american citizens
but also also um today in the decision
where they're saying that we do not have
the right to
to try to regulate and make sure that we
have clean air to breathe yeah um and
and all that darkness all that darkness
in the supreme court there is a glimmer
of light and this is it
and i think this picture is is the
epitome of it is that
little girls in america
little black girls in america can look
up and say
the supreme court even though it's not
making decisions that's helping me there
is someone there who looks like me
there's hope
there is hope i go back to uh star wars
they don't know that they're the baddies
right they don't know that they're the
empire yeah yeah they don't know that
but there's one point in um i think it's
rogue one that's one of the best star
wars movies there is i don't care what
you say that's one of the best ones
and they say entire
entire
rebellions are built on hope entire
rebellions are built on hope
and we have to we have to rebel against
this idea that only the supreme court
right now is the one that can make
decisions that we can't change this
right we the people can change this you
can do it
you can go elect pro-democracy senators
into the senate yes you can and and and
no maybe this election
won't get us there but if you don't go
vote for the pro-democracy now they're
going to tear down your democracy even
more right because that's one of the
dark things that we we have i mean you
had a whole president like presidential
campaign that was run on the word hope
which was obama's right you know like
these are things that actually can drive
a movement of people and the other thing
too is like
whether republicans like it or not guess
who just got extra protection
guess who just got herself and her
family protection against people who
don't agree with the color of her skin
the rights that she'd been given or the
place on the supreme court bench that
she now has
those white fascist [ __ ] trumped up
[ __ ] are gonna be super pissed
because guess what as quickly as they
they voted to act to actually give
protection to these supreme court
justices
now she was just sworn in she gets that
same protection so i'm sorry but you
guys you guys made it this way and she's
gonna probably receive a ton of hate in
a ton
of disgusting terrible things that come
her way and it's not deserved in any way
it is not deserved but now she has that
extra kind of umbrella of protection
and that'll piss them off oh yeah
just like just like this decision here
we'll piss them off here's another
little glimmer of hope um regardless of
who voted and why they voted this is a
glimmer of hope
abc news has a story here breaking the
supreme court rules in favor of the bite
administration as it seeks to end former
president trump's remaining mexico quote
unquote policy for asylum seekers now we
know
that during the trump administration
they were very vile and and treated
migrants very inhumanely women children
men the like and it didn't matter where
they were from because a lot of these
people who were migrants that were
seeking asylum weren't from mexico a lot
of a lot of boneheads in this country
especially racist boneheads don't
actually understand central america they
think the entirety of central america is
mexico which it is not it is not there's
different countries in central america
and a lot of these folks would come from
honduras um and other central american
countries but the remaining mexico
policy what it did was when these people
when these migrants would cross they
would send them back to mexico which is
not their country that's not their
country that's not where they're from
that's not their home so basically
putting them in this sort of purgatory
border purgatory
which caused them to only want to cross
the border even more back into the
united states because that was really
their only option now what the biden
administration did is said no we're not
going to do the remain in mexico we're
not going to create this situation where
migrants are have to create tent cities
they live in border purgatory because
they're trying to seek asylum here we
will provide them a place here even if
it's in detention
um to to seek asylum here if they cross
the border that's what the biden
administration uh had decided to get rid
of remain in mexico now the argument
here in this case was that the biden
administration didn't go about it
correctly but the supreme court with
roberts and kavanaugh surprisingly
decided five to four that yes the biden
administration did do it properly and
did
undo the remaining mexico policy
properly
uh they didn't rule against the actual
policy itself just the fact of how the
biden administration
undid that policy yeah that's what they
actually ruled on so that's important to
know when you're talking about roberts
and kavanaugh
making this decision they weren't ruling
in favor or against the remaining mexico
policy they were ruling in favor of the
bite administration the government the
executive branch on how they actually
undid that policy so keep that in mind
when you're when you're thinking about
this decision than the 5-4 vote because
that's important when you're talking
about kavanaugh and robertson right um
but this is really
this is a big victory um for migrants um
that are seeking asylum in this country
not
they people framed it up as a
as a victory for the biden
administration but i i don't see it as a
victory for the bible i still think it
is i i don't see it as a victory this
was just something that was just
decent
yeah yeah but also just the way that it
was done is like poorly executed where i
was like oh this is a clear violation
this isn't something actually right
right well you know it's the same thing
i said when biden actually undid the
whole
uh
uh
lgbtq in the army you remember
trans trans people
donald trump sent out a tweet and was
doing policy policy by tweet yep and he
basically threw the dod doj into a
turmoil over trans folks in the military
um and one of first biden's first acts
was to undo that and everyone hailed it
as a victory i'm like
it's just a decent thing to do we
actually shouldn't be we act again just
like liz cheney should not be deemed a
hero for being on the committee and he
adhering to the truth to protect our
democracy
not necessarily she should be deemed as
a hero as she's just doing her duty as
the same way as the president biden or
any other president actually making sure
that people have equality and equity
especially inside the department of
defense and inside our military that
shouldn't be a big ask and like you're
pointing out here i think it shouldn't
be a big ass to to treat migrants no
matter which country they're from with a
little bit of [ __ ] humanity right
exactly
if we really are going to be pro-life
and would be the true christians and
followers of jesus christ let's follow
the word of god let's follow the word of
christ let's actually do
what the gospels say that we should do
let's shelter let's feed let's clothe we
should we should be the people that care
for other humans but under trump and
republican type of life or or or world
that they want to live in it is very
much if you don't look like me if you
don't sound like me if you aren't the
same class or status as me then i will
say you can go [ __ ] yourself and it's
unfortunate that is the world we live in
especially you know like i am of the
fortunate ability where i have lighter
skin but i have hispanic last name i've
certainly got my fair share of [ __ ]
but if you have people who are seeking
refuge and asylum then you should take
them in help them out isn't that what
america is all about this is that what
jesus said right exactly isn't that what
america is all about isn't that what
christian vows are about about bringing
people in and taking them as your own
and caring for them when others won't
like i have a history of of of catholic
fate and christian faith
and
you know i'm no longer you know with the
church i'm i'm uh an atheist but
it is not hard to be like yo you're
going against the things that jesus
spoke and gave about but i also speaking
of supreme court and and they're you
know acting
trying to appear like uh decent human
beings you've got people like justice
thomas who is the basically the
surrogate viewpoint or or
uh soapbox for ginny thomas
and this one
i think is insane
we have justice thomas now citing a
debunked claim that coveted vaccines are
made with cells from aborted children
right this guy rarely said [ __ ] years
ago and now he's coming out with all
these [ __ ] dissents and opinions
where he's now saying that oh yeah the
vaccines that are made are coming from
aborted children why are we
why is this written where was this
written was this written in the road
decision no go down this is for a uh
it's a um
it is for
it was for a case that they that they
did not want to take up which is a legal
challenge oh health care workers who
oppose the state vaccine mandate on
religious grounds
and uh thomas as well as
alito and gorsuch
were people that wanted they said the
court should have taken it up but they
ended up not taking it up
um
they decided though in other news they
decided to take up a case in north
carolina about voting rights right which
is
huge another [ __ ] scary huge impact
can you find me something on that i'll
link it on that um
while i go back and look um
because it looks like there's a few
things now trending
um and i don't know if they're breaking
news mcconnell is in the news for his
statements against joe biden but we also
have
um
maybe i'm
i thought i just
saw oh jesus is lord
and that goes back to what you were just
saying
yes jesus and you know they're talking
about migrants and if they really
believe these things you know
unfortunately uh for these white
republicans jesus like
right right right
jesus wasn't white jesus was brown okay
he didn't look like you he probably most
likely most definitely 100 percent
didn't believe the same [ __ ] that
you're throwing around he actually loved
people assuming that jesus was a real
person and he did exist in this world of
the bible let's say
he is 100
the opposite of what you are preaching
he is the socialist he is the person
that cares for other people he is the
one that said hey we should probably
make collectively this world a better
place well that's why they're saying
outright that they want to be the
christian taliban like now they're
embracing this like oh yeah because
exactly that's what i mean before it was
like oh if there was a taliban caravan
of cars with trucks or trucks and flags
and guns and people [ __ ] whoo
and there's a comparison photo of
another caravan or trucker convoy with
people with trump flags and maga and you
know republicans and holding their guns
and going pew pew
show me the difference show me the
difference the only difference between
the two
is that it's the color of their skin
that's right but you are the same it's
the same reason why you see a comparison
photo of lauren bobert with guns in the
background on screen and then someone
who's making a terrorist video with guns
in the background
in random propaganda-like flags there is
no difference you have the same
ideologies so here is the an article
from mbr the us supreme court announced
thursday that it's agreed to hear a case
next term so this is and the supreme
court didn't make a decision on this
term they're just saying we are going to
hear it in the next term of the supreme
court we're going to take this case up
what it could do is it could up end
election laws across the country now
what the
this is a case out of north carolina
it's called moore versus harper uh i was
reading a little bit about this before
coming on the air that the
if if it goes the way that you would
think it would go which would be a 6-3
decision what would happen is that the
state courts do not have the ability to
un to
rule on state laws on federal elections
so let me be clear on this
so in a federal election whether it be
congress senate or the presidency those
federal elections that happen in states
that states have the authority over
states run the elections not the federal
government now the federal government
has the um oversight while they did with
the civil rights act before they tore it
down they don't have as much oversight
over some of these states but what this
case is saying what this k if they rule
in favor of this case what is going to
happen
is if if a state
brings a case to a state court whatever
state it may be
that state court does not have the
authority over state law because it has
to do with a federal election
this is the slow moving coup in in
effect uh folks this is what they're
doing this is why i say it is so
important that this election is the most
important one and as soon as this
election is over the next one is the
most important one they are coming for
your right to vote because they know
that democracy is their enemy and when i
say they i mean the christian taliban i
mean the maga fascist i mean the let's
go brandon nazis they are full on ready
to make this an authoritarian state they
do not want democracy democracy is their
enemy because it they it it delivers
equity and equality to everything they
hate women black folks
latino folks lgbt community it delivers
equity and equality over time to those
folks and yes it's not perfect democracy
isn't but they are terrified terrified
that they're going to be the oppressed
ones and i mean trumped up white people
that's what i mean here and this is only
a move towards making sure that
republicans in these states have the
authority to do whatever they want with
no oversight from the state court over
these state laws that is what they're
doing what's this last uh mallory mcroe
we know she's a she's a superstar um
what was this uh that's the that's a
tweet that uh
that was sent to me um
okay yeah um this is the thread
from mj we've seen we've seen um um
mallory mcmorrow here she's a state
legislator
let me see if i can get the thing to
there we go she's a state senator in
michigan's 13th district right
but she has given several pleas on her
senate floor in her state on video and
boy are they
are are they compelling so go check out
her account follow her
and you can find those videos but she
has a thread here she says today's news
that the supreme court is taking up um
moore versus harper case ahead of the
2024 should scare the hell out of all of
us this court could gut our presidential
elections the same way they just gutted
roe here's a threat on why it's so
dangerous and what we can do about it so
i'll retweet this thread yeah so thank
you mallory for um
for for posting this thread um and
everyone go check out this thread and
start talking about it see you can't
just read these things right yeah you
gotta you gotta start talking about you
gotta amplify it if you did not
acknowledge right if for that person
that commented on your video or uh
whatever earlier it's say like stop the
propaganda stop spreading this stop
letting this stuff get any air it's like
you need to we'll say it again
you have to bring it up you have to
discuss it if you don't then things like
this will go unnoticed and then you'll
say wait wait what happened to these
rights or these these laws or or this
voice or or whatever it might be that
this person once had goes oh no that was
two two two cycles ago we we voted that
thing out and you're like well when did
that happen what for what it was like oh
well this other thing like well why
didn't anyone tell me it's because you
said just shut the [ __ ] up and stop
talking about it but we need to actually
talk about it right you have to amplify
what they're doing you have to show what
they're doing and you can't just you
can't just read it now we amplify it
here with our microphone but you can
amplify it you can amplify it whether it
be with your community members your
friends your family uh your your fellow
parishioners if you go to church if you
go to a community center
if you go to a pta meeting wherever
you're at you have to amplify these
things you have to you must talk about
these things jesus christ in the grocery
store for crying out loud because our
democracy depends on it for you to get
the messaging out because people we know
this people aren't paying as much
attention as they need to and they're
missing it that's why we have to show
them what these people are doing because
if they ignore it
we're all [ __ ] we're all screwed we
cannot ignore the fact that they're
trying to steal away our democracy i
mean just like christina says you can't
ignore cancer right if you do
it will begin to spread if you don't say
hey we gotta treat this with either
chemotherapy or surgery or other types
of procedures if you don't do that it
will spread and it'll ruin the rest of
the host which is the american democracy
our country that we know as the united
states of america if we don't do
something
then we will fail and we will die and
the best treatment for this american
taliban type cancer
is for you to use your ballot to use
democracy and use that sledgehammer of
democracy to smash up fascism because
people in this country still believe in
the vote even though they're not paying
attention to what's happening they still
believe in the vote they still believe
in the american way we just have to show
them that these fascists are not for
america they're not for democracy
they're not
for the way of life that these people
know
so keep listening here on the tony
michaels podcast every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific we will yell and
scream into this microphone
make sure to go follow us on twitter at
tonymichaelspod the bone end of the week
poll will be out today and we'll be out
today and also follow us and subscribe
on youtube where you can vote as well
i'm not going to encourage you to double
vote because that would sound trumpy but
you know here here it's not as arranged
as some of the state elections i'll
grant you that much but we are free and
fair
in our polling because here's what
happens you vote for the bone end of the
week you decide we break it down
tomorrow in the second hour the tony
michaels podcast will go through the
bone of the week you can also download
bonehead of the week in and of itself
every sunday and download every single
episode while you're at it on on apple
spotify google your favorite directories
until tomorrow gabe until tomorrow surfs
up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking